[Music]
as the temperatures get higher
so does the risk to life
these firefighters are getting ready
for what could be a busy few days ahead
and their main concern
field fires
grass fires and field fires and rural
fires um can be a massive impact because
of the the speed of development
and obviously we are
an urban area as well so obviously if
that's going towards buildings and
things then you've got to start
evacuating
and obviously people going to lose
properties a discarded bottle would
magnify light like the magnifying glass
effect can cause a fire that that's
quite a common cause as well barbecues
outside you know the little disposable
bbqs people not putting them out
properly duties for today we'll be going
up casper park while firefighters brace
themselves for the emergency call
even the everyday tasks will be tougher
firefighters are used to dealing with
high temperatures but not for long
periods of time the next few days will
be a real test on their resources and
perhaps a sign of things to come
the dangers posed by this heat wave
enough for the government to hold a
second emergency meeting in a matter of
days we are as ready as we can be
obviously we're communicating strongly
to the public about the sort of
behaviors they need to put in place to
make sure they and their neighbors
stay safe as we go through extreme
events like the monday and tuesday next
week
we will learn from them about the
adaptations we need to make so for
example on a micro level we'll learn
about the little bits of equipment that
melt and can't take the heat and that
will have to think about how they are
constructed and we'll also all learn
about the kind of behaviors that we need
to cope with this heat which we may
often uh uh you know put in place when
we're on holiday
but which more overseas but more often
we may have to do at home
a rare red weather warning is already in
place for the first time though it's for
heat
bringing with it warnings of severe
disruption to services to railways to
schools to hospitals
the country could soon be the hottest
it's ever been the looming question is
how well will it cope
from the government's perspective
we've discovered
huge vulnerability
which really um
will affect our resilience and this is
this is the key thing our resilience in
the future that we were perhaps uh
ignoring the piece of work that the
government really must address now with
urgency as we were saying indeed in
november at the uh cop 26 climate change
meetings um what is our plan for the
long-term new term
as the temperatures continue to ramp up
the message to the public is to slow
down charlotte lomas sky news